[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants et bien
nous allons pour découvrir le monde
merveilleux du jeu d'échecs est bien
accueillie en nino maisuradze et bonjour
nino alors ni notions va rappeler comme
que tu es tu es m féminin maître
international féminin d'échec donc tu
nous viennent de géorgie et tu tues
viennent d'être naturalisée française
donc tu vas tu vas faire partie
peut-être de l'équipe de france oui
petite précision je suis pas un gros
naturalisé mais je serai dans voilà dans
quelques mois je crois oui
donc voilà j'ai fait partie des
fédérations françaises déjà g20 de
changer la fédération donc voilà
peut-être français
peut-être alors en attendant tu va nous
accompagner sur des gones al tv spéciale
leçon 1
pour débutants mais on va découvrir le
jeu d'échecs alors on va parler d'abord
de de l'historique du jeu en fait donc
c'est un vieux je veux tu t'y connais un
peu sur l'histoire ou pas oui bien sûr
them
il faut dire et il ya beaucoup de
l'hygiène sur jeu d'échec très attirant
et surtout il faut quand même on à
nouveau rappelé que ses joues vient de
landes
même s'il ya plusieurs hypothèses où ça
peut venir également de perth
oui mais moi quand j'étais petit
ci-après comme ça qui s'était inventé
dans land il y à rouen qui a commandé il
ya un roi qui s'ennuyer en fait il
voulait qu'on l'envoie là divertissent
alors il y avait déjà la fameuse légende
de 6 à lesage et qui aurait appris le
roi enfin donc le jeu le jeu d'échecs
aux endroits à son droit et qu'il faut
le remercier lui a dit me demande moi ce
que tu veux il m'a dit je voudrais
simplement quelque chose très simple
grain de riz sur la première et la vidéo
sur la deuxième jusqu'à la 64e le
royaume aussi c'est que ça c'est qui est
drôle oui l'unrwa qui n'a pas compris qu
est-ce que c'était aux justes il a dit
c'est trop facile et oui et puis en fait
au final le grand nombre de grains de
riz si on les ajoute ça fait plus que le
nombre de grains de riz actuellement
produits dans le monde donc ça fait
quand même beaucoup qui fait vraiment
courir la terre on peut dire aussi le
jeu d'échecs est un jeu très très
puissant puisqu'il ya plus de parties
d'échecs possible que d'atomes dans
l'univers visible ce qui ferait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup alors on va rappeler
l'histoire donc 5ème siècle en inde
ensuite sans doute passé dans le monde
arabe via la perse
d'où l'expression d'ailleurs échec et
mat puisque ça vient de chez amath wii
qui veut dire le roi est mort un
géorgien s'est toujours chamade terre
c'est à huy en géorgien aussi voilà qui
est à côté donc le roi est mort le donc
c'est le but du jeu d'échec c'est de
mettre le roi à mort puis en plus a
ensuite s'est passé en europe via
l'espagne alors de la conquête arabe
de l'espagne et puis à partir de
l'espagne après en europe puis dans le
monde entier
ça aussi donc ça aussi percer à lorient
via la chine et au japon et les échelles
japonais qu'on peut diverger mais
aujourd'hui le jeu mondialement connue
c'est celui qui est passé par l'europe
le jeu d'échecs mais c'est à transformer
il faut dire de dans le temps au début
je croyais quatre joueurs au début qui
jouait aux échecs il y avait les pièces
et oui les qu'audrey pour départ
s'appelait le chat tu rends gars ont
vraiment le jeu des quatre armes et un
autre américain
et puis donc c'est un jeu qui dont les
règles ont évolué au fil du temps même
encore récemment il ya des réponses
changé par rapport notamment contrôle de
temps qu'on a qu'on donne aux joueurs ce
genre de choses donc c'est un jeu qui
dont les règles ont été perfectionnées
au cours des siècles donc vous imaginez
la perfection que peuvent avoir atteint
atteinte ces règles alors à noter aussi
dans le parcours du jeu d'échecs comme
ça donc de l'inde au cinquième siècle
via le monde arabe puis l'espagne et
c'est que les plus grands joueurs du
monde dont on a des traités très ancien
il ya des traités du 12e siècle un nom
des traits même peut-être même avant
très anciens avaient des problèmes
d'échec les meilleurs joueurs du monde
ont suivi en général les nations qui
dominait le monde culturel ou
scientifique ou économique
donc les arabes en premier ensuite
l'espagne lors de la conquête de
l'amérique du sud est et l'or qui arrive
et en europe
ensuite il ya eu l'italie à la
renaissance la france lors de la
révolution française avec philidor le
fameux café la régence puis ensuite les
anglais avaient stone town est ensuite
les américains aussi avec murphy
mais au moment de l'indépendance à des
amériques enfin des états unis il ya eu
ensuite les autrichiens et les allemands
avaient steinitz tarrach au début du feu
19e 20e fillon 20e avant les fameuses
guerre mondiale etc et ensuite il ya eu
évidemment les russes et les américains
lors de la guerre froide qui ont culminé
avec le match fischer ce pas ce qui est
aujourd'hui en 2008
et bien c'est un indien qui est champion
du monde donc ses revenus aux origines
c'est vishy anand qui est indiens et les
chinois aussi qui perce beaucoup
notamment chez les filles il ya déjà eu
plusieurs champions du monde féminine
chez les filles mais aussi chez les
hommes je crois que la chine a fini
troisième
l'avant dernière olympiade donc d'échec
la compétition internationaux qui
démontre que le jeu d'échecs de
rebasculer en orient notamment avec la
percée de la chine et de l'inde au
niveau au niveau économique mondiale
alors ça c'est pour l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs maintenant on va revenir au jeu
lui-même qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
déjà oui j'ai quand même préciser donc
c'est le joug qui rassemble beaucoup aux
batailles
il faut dire combat bien sûr c'est pour
ça et toujours il ya les grands
généralistes et râler les personnes
militaires ou stratégiquement impliqué
dans les politiques comme napoléon
d'ailleurs aussi qu'ils aiment beaucoup
les échecs c'est vrai dans quelques
parties n'a pour lui oui mais histoire
qui nous regarde quelques parties
napoléon mouais
et d'ailleurs je sais pas pourquoi il ya
les jeunes qui circulent en géorgie et
sur napoléon ii mais qui n'est pas
forcément connu pour les français
quelqu'un elle était emprisonnée il y
avait ses amis qui lui n'en noyer une
position d'échec oui sert à cacher une
plan stratégique pour échapper aux est
passée jean paul et fait les comptes
pour les gens en géorgie c'est vraiment
connu en russie aussi cette histoire
après je sais pas non mais par contre il
n'a voulu a pas eu ils ont dit non mais
à sainte-hélène notamment napoléon cite
d'ailleurs dans le mémorial de
sainte-hélène qui l'a dicté à aux
personnes qui l'accompagnaient lors de
cet exil son dernier exil il expliqué
clairement qui faisait des parties
d'échecs oui c'était vraiment un féru de
jeux d'échecs donc jeu de stratégie par
excellence alors maintenant on va parler
du jeu lui-même allons on va parler de
l'échiquier et avoir 64 cases déjà
commencé et il ya donc juste je vais
demander à la régie de nous m
l'échiquier voilà sur l'écran sans voilà
ici on a un échiquier vide donc comme tu
disais tu avais roya effectivement 64
cases alors comment on peut les compter
ses cases ça fait alors ses huit sur
huit
donc ici on a un deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit cases et vers le haut
on a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 dont 8 x 8 64 cases
vous pouvez les compteurs la main tel
est pas trompée avec les damiers qui
peut avoir plus de cas aux échecs c'est
toujours 64 cas ça n'existait pas une
échelle plus large ou à petit voilà
l'échiquier voilà exactement l'échiquier
ses 8 x 8 alors que le damier c'est dix
fois disent oui le damier ça peut jouer
sur vie choisir 8 aussi normalement plus
classique se redit ce alors que les
échecs et voilà c'est chic et ça voilà
alors pour parricide chic et alors
comment maintenant on a on a noté donc
on a noté cet échiquier alors je crois
qu'il ya ni noah une façon de le
de le repérer les cases je crois que
c'est important
oui bien sûr vous voyez sur l'échiquier
donc il y à lourdes alphabétique avec
abc des faits h et aussi numérotée à
gauche ça ici en verre se sont abaissées
d e f g h
ce qu'on appelle les je crois qu'on peut
lire les colonnes voilà donc ça c'est ça
par exemple celle que je marque en verre
à gauche ici celle ci qu'on appelle ça
la colonne ah oui et là c'est le ranger
en bas et ça cela arrange et numéro un
mais c'est pas juste qu'en mode donc
disons que horizontalement sait on les
appelle les ranger alors que
verticalement on s'appelle les colons
voilà donc ici colonnes à willy colonne
mais jusque là par exemple colonna pour
dessiner de quoi on parle voilà hélas et
les ranger donc on les appelle
effectivement on les numéros donnés par
des chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6 là vous voyez
que c'est un peu comme n'importe quel
plan une carte de la ville et où il ya
même région sont définis par juste par
exemple et 4 fait et on veut montrer
donc par exemple à cazaux 4
effectivement donc abcde ici 1,2 alors
un deux trois quatre
voilà cette quasi si cette quasi si
c'est la cas de 4 à gauche et de voilà
je vais la montrer en jaune ici voilà
c'est la casse à en réunir son 22e plus
tard de toute façon donc à noter
également il faut pas se tromper c'est
qu'ils arrivent souvent le
aux débutants de ne pas me très chic et
pas correctement parce que remarqué si
vous tournez l'échiquier ça peut être
donner n'importe quoi il faut toujours
que la casse clair soit à droite en bas
voilà donc ici vous devinez que vous
avez chéquier correctement placé voilà
donc ça c'est important
par convention par convention on met
toujours la case blanche à droite parce
que si on inverse
c'est toujours correct tu auras toujours
64 cases et tout mais c'est la
convention c'est qu'on met la case
blanche à droite oui ça c'est après on
sait que plus tard les règles de rock
taussat mais après ça marche plus et on
inverse
donc si votre chéquier numérotée retenir
qu'un alphabet ça doit être en bas pour
que ce soit lisible déjà mais si votre
chien n'est pas numérotées il n'y a pas
de notation là dessus dans ce que vous
retenez le cash les loquace droite en
bas ça doit être blanc voilà d'ailleurs
à pas confondre avec le damier aussi ou
celle inverse c'est la case noire qui à
droite donc le damier ça rien à voir
donc confondez pas le dernier 10 x 10
cases noires à droite avec l'échiquier
qui lui c'est le jeu d'échec c'est pas
le même jeu c'est 8 x 8 et donc carte
blanche à droite et donc on a parlé
effectivement des colonnes vers le haut
comme ça a b c d e f g h et les ranger 1
2 3 4 6 et donc maintenant vous rappelle
que à part les colons est rangé il
existe les diagonales aux seychelles et
diagonale on repère les diagonales alors
par exemple ici souci est une diagonale
oui alors comment comment on distingue
cette cette chose là c'est les
diagonales dans son repaire ici la
différence par contre par abord qu lone
ranger que l'on appelle les vicas donc
jusqu'à vous alors que les diagonales il
peut exister les diagonales l'hongrie
angoulins qu'on grandit roulant qu'on
appelle à 8,15 où ça peut être aussi
reconnu à juste au casse par exemple la
tête on peut montrer des malades ou
casque à ce que ça paie donne alors une
diagonale à deux cases par exemple ces
alors donc celle ci par exemple ici on
va le montrer en jaune ici voilà ça
c'est une petite diagonale fait juste
bonne à ces petites diagonales c'est la
diagonale à cette baie 8,1 vous pouvez
régler sur le très chic et à cette build
a pas confondre avec cette diagonale là
qu'on appelle h 1 à 8 et celle qu'on
appelle la grande diagonale la grande
diagonale parce qu'effectivement ça il
ya deux grandes diagonales les à celle
là évidemment sur casse blanche ici est
celle ci sur case noire à part ça donc à
savoir que haut il y allait d'un mail a
eu droit ce qui compte c'est pas alors
on va enlever un peut-être un peu les
cases effectivement donc il faut juste
avoir le temps de le faire parce que il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont marqués
pour une facilité donc la vision
donc vous avez bien retenu les
diagonales et ranger les colons donc on
va repérer ici ça s'arrête là elle dame
tout ce côté là on prétendre que m
voilà on va séparer on va simplement
mettre toutes les cases grand
l'aberration
donc en fait toute la moitié gauche de
l'échiquier on appellera sallèles dame
qui séparait ici vous allez voir
pourquoi parce que on va vous apprendre
les places en débit est hélas est
scellée loin
d'ailleurs on voit bien qu'il ya les
rois qui sont placés pourquoi on a mis
les rois parce que vos échecs il peut
pas y avoir de position sans endroit ça
n'existe pas donc il faut au mollet
droit pour que la position soit légale
tant koala en jaune c'est les rois et
donc envers par conséquence les dents
voilà nos choix quoi là on a fait le
tour du tableau du plateau passons
maintenant je crois qu'on a tous vu les
colonnes les ranger les diagonales
on a vu les petites diagonales les
grandes diagonales maintenant viennent
sépare effectivement l'aileron allèles
d'un on a bien expliqué que l'échiquier
avait une case blanche
à droite on a bien tout résumé et
maintenant on va vous montrer
l'échiquier tel qu'il est au début de la
partie
la pression était par travailler tout de
suite ça s'est rempli donc voilà toutes
les pièces telles que son ange et
audible aux antilles qui font l'objet de
cette de cette leçon s'associe à savoir
chaque adversaire il
sps alors cette pièce donc on voit ici
il ya ici à 8 pions voix 8 pions les
pieds c'est range donc sur 1er et 2e
rangée et sur 7e ou 8e c'est toujours ça
il n'y a pas d'autre possibilité
au début ces armes alors les pions sont
toujours sur la deuxième rangée pour les
blancs sur la septième rangée pour les
noirs c'est le là où vous expliquer déjà
donc des nominations donc il y a le roi
alors le roi une pièce plus important
quand vous déjà défini ses parts à voir
un homme voilà ça c'est le roi si on
voit le roi blanc et jaune en france et
le roi bien sûr parce que ça n'existait
pas avoir deux ou trois ans suit ensuite
il ya les temps donc chacun à sa dame et
pour mieux comprendre à imaginer c'est
leur droit et donc la réelle mais juste
aux échecs on le donnait la dame qui est
pratiquement associe avec la reine
donc on est marc pellerin en août parce
que on ne pas s'être trompé avec après
vous allez voir qu'on ne marque par
rapport aux initiales le roi ce sera r
alors que si on appelle la dame renzaho
données dauzère bien sûr donc ce sera
donc l'euro et les dents mais c'est ça
en fait le donc voilà donc on a vu le
roi
la dame alors elles sont toujours placés
au même endroit donc ici juste à s'en
être juste à côté
donc après il y aller fouet chacun ado
fou de fou pour les blancs d'oeuf ou
pour les noirs donc les fous sont à côté
du couple royal
oui c'est un peu comme le conseillère de
bons pour se rappeler où le fou du roi
tout simplement l'amuseur public à celui
qui a amusé le monarque
on voit les toujours à côté du roi oui à
près d'un an par rapport aux différents
paye sa définition autrement il ya
certains qui préfèrent appelle les
éléphants je ne sais pas quoi et alors
on peut le dire ça effectivement suivant
les pays s'appelle pas paru autant le
roi et la dame sont toujours aux même
façon alors en arabe le fictivement je
crois que c'est l'éléphant et on a dû
faire une représentation de chez qui il
sait trop quelle votre échec et que vous
avez chez vous il se trouve que vous
aurez payé senti vos différentes mais à
comprendre des poissons
à partir du moment où vous savez comment
les déplacés et les lire ne vous appelez
plus ou moins qu'on voulait mais nous on
vous dont les non officiels
voilà après ça soit rien n'émerge pas
qu'en anglais c'est l'évêque c'est pas
le fou c'est l'évêque qui changent et
c'est l'évêque donc ses ouailles et
c'est ça dépend des pays après
évidemment de conchos terre en typo
comme le conseiller du roi et d'hambourg
voilà les familles royales
alors ensuite il nous reste ces pièces
là donc les canonniers donc ça c'est les
cavaliers est pratiquement toujours
représenté par la tête de cheval voilà
donc après les fous donc les cavaliers
donc là c'est facile on cavaliers donc
c'est un peu comme le chiffre tarn et
all star ac et protège le croit donc les
chevaliers bon alors évidemment assez
représentée par un cheval ça s'appelle
cavaliers ont dit plus tôt on peut dire
qu'on peut dire cheval aussi oui les
amateurs ou une habitude chez valve
je vais aller là où l'autre l'un ou
l'autre indifféremment mais plutôt
cavaliers dans l'anneau station la
notation claasen les livres et ses
terrasses escaliers
voilà et enfin les taux les tours donc
là les tours on voit bien les tours du
château fort donc ils sont aux
extrémités ici complet mais voilà voilà
les tours et donc il ya après les pions
qu'on soit on compare avec les soldats
qui sont placés bien sûr des vents à vos
problèmes donc les pions des combes les
fantassins qui sont placés devant
l'armée prêts à attaquer au moindre
signe au moindre signe guerrier donc le
prêt à se lancer dans la bataille et qui
sont les plus nombreux donc c'est
sacrifier le plus facilement comme nallo
rêver on sacrifie plus allègrement que
les pièces donc pour élire plus
facilement on récapitule tout simplement
qu'est donc il y a le roi avec entre
guillemets sa famille qui s'appelle adam
entouré avec les conseillères et après
par le chiffre d' armer les cavaliers et
bien sûr vers la france contre les
forces entre guillemets les tours qui
protège et défend les soldats voilà
alors on va juste rappeler donc
effectivement le couple royal donc et au
centre comme vous
airwide sommes bien au centre alors
juste pour distinguer comment placer les
pièces regardez c'est totalement
symétrique est en fait la dame elle est
sur sa couleur la case noire et la dame
blanche sur la case blanche donc à noter
donc c'est ça et après le roi sur la
case juste à côté les 37 pas d'une façon
assez voilà alors par exemple si vous
vous trompez sur l'échiquier si vous
mettez la case noire à droite et que
vous dites que la dame sur sa couleur
vous allez inverser la position du roi
et la dame c'est pour ça qu'il faut
garder toujours là la case à droite par
convention évidemment pour ne pas pour
ne pas se tromper qu on vous rappelle
également que c'est toujours les blancs
qui commande ce qui est aussi erreurs
habituelles de débutantes et qui savent
qu'ils ont parfois dû commencer avec les
noirs oui c'est la règle c'est les
blancs qui commence à sécher toujours
les bleus repartent il ressort qui va
commencer voilà alors maintenant qu'on a
vu évidemment dans cette leçon on
regardera pas le déplacement des pièces
qui feront l'objet de leçons ultérieure
mais par contre
on va parler de l'éthique je crois oui
un petit pot pour rappeler les tic aux
effies donc bien sûr si vous jouez entre
les amis vous vous comportez plus ou
moins qu'on voulait mais si vous avez à
nu des impôts respectait les éthiques
reconnu disney internationalement c'est
un déjà serré la main de vos adversaires
avant commencé la partie et après aussi
ça se fait toujours et à la fin aussi
donc
au début on sert le mans c'est pas
important qui va tant que la mort
première c'est par rapport à hier une
première peut-être par contre à la fin
c'est le perdant qui doit donc temps de
l'amant oui bonjour si vous faites
passer très impoli ce sera mal vu donc
anti poux ça donc on prévient également
que aux échecs il faut pas parler quand
vous et ça c'est bien sûr n'applique pas
si vous voulez entre les amis mais dans
le tournoi par exemple on n'a pas droit
parlait en or sauf pour dire échec
oui ça aussi bon on peut pas trop
sensible qu'est ce que ça veut dire
après il y à aussi à savoir oser au
tournoi si vous touchez une pièce il
faut le jouer
vous n'avez pas le droit de toucher une
pièce et a prévu une autre pièce des
places et aussi il ya plusieurs règles
comme ça donc par rapport que ça va se
distinguer si vous jouez chez vous en 3
min joueurs au niveau andy goode tournoi
donc si vous touchez également par
exemple qui est adverse d'adversaires
normalement si vous pouvez la prendre
vous avez plus droit de ne pas prendre
mais voilà donc si on touche une pièce
alors si ces pièces à nous il faut la
jouer
oui pas si on touche une pièce adverse
il faut la prendre c'est prenable
ils veulent apprendre or s'il faut la
prendre si la règle nous aiment pas de
vue notre coup il sait il y à une pièce
qui n'est pas bien centré sur une case
et vous avez envie de le corriger
il faut déclarer votre attention en
avance bien sûr droit de toucher les
pistes mais dans ces cas où dit non j'ai
c'est pas pour jouer mais c'est juste
donc il faut dire jade ou jade ou alors
ça c'est un mot du vieux français au
lycée une mythique qui s'emploie au
niveau international oui il faudra donc
c'est là où on voit que je vis en
général jadot et
c'est là qu'on voit que le jeu est passé
ça veut dire que vous dansez mon malheur
vous touchez ps et vous n'êtes pas
obligé jouer cette pièce est à savoir
aussi une fois vous déplacer une ps si
vous avez lâché la main le coup est déjà
fait voilà donc quand on lâche une pièce
coup joué donc ça serait la réponse est
qu en général
par contre si vous permet encore lâché
l'amant vous avez droite et reprend ses
coûts mais vous serez obligé de jouer
cette pièce là voilà cirque si vous
n'avez pas encore lâché la pièce vous
pouvez toujours la remettre à sa
position initiale vous devez la jouer
puisque vous l'avez touché mais vous
pouvez changer le coup tant que vous
l'avez pas lâcher tant que vous n'avez
pas lâcher effectivement votre pièce sur
une case donne alors je vais peut-être
raconter une anecdote quand même là
dessus je veux pas si le situe la
connaît mais kasparov lui même avait
lâché les pièces je crois qu'il avait
lâché une pièce vassa judit polgar willy
tsao cevoli chaîne va dire dans les
succès dans les arènes et ça fait toute
une histoire parce que je lui dis tu
pollues avait dit messi mais s'il a
lâché la pièce quatre ans maintenant je
n'ai pas lâché et finalement l' arbitre
a donné raison kasparov caisse pour
enfin pu reprendre son coup et jouer ça
la même pièce évident puisqu'il l'avait
touché sur une autre case sauf qu'à la
vidéo la vidéo quand même quoi qu'il
avait effectivement lâché la pièce dont
qu'il avait triché kasparov même me
voyez même les plus grands joueurs
peuvent arriver à tricher mais ça a été
reconnue comme une triche et regardez
même aujourd'hui on en parle donc ça
veut dire quand même que c'est quand ça
arrive c'est pas très bien vu c'est pas
très bien vu surtout si vous jouez face
à une dame alors faut être encore plus
galants faut être encore plus correct
que bon encore que si vous êtes face à
un homme sans risquer de prendre une
baffe
vous prenez vos risques mais les
rectorats ce strict ou quand vous voyez
justin corto petite différence
d'ailleurs en ajoutons dans les tournois
vous pouvez aussi voir la pendule
n'hésiterai pas qu'est ce qu'on sait sur
quoi on clique c'est pas forcément dans
les tic mais on nous explique à la
maison souvent de jouer son pendule
oui et si nous il existe aussi le point
de vue voilà les tournois dans les
tournois mais même à la maison sur une
joue beaucoup de gens s'intéressent
parce que celle attendue
si on veut jouer aux échecs rapidement
parce que sinon ça peut durer des jours
évidemment c'est pas le but
en général on a une double pendule et
dont on peut en parler très rapidement
si simplement donc on a par exemple dix
minutes par joueur pour jouer toute la
partie donc c'est un capital temps il ya
une double pendule donc cancer vous de
jouer
c'est votre temps qui diminue vous avez
votre propre pendule qui diminue quand
vous avez joué vous appuyez sur la
pendule
votre pendule s'arrête votre capital
temps est préservée par contre c'est le
capital tant de l'adversaire qui
diminuée si vous passez en dessous de
zéro eh bien vous avez perdu la partie
donc il faut absolument jouer rapidement
de façon à ce que le temps ne soit pas
un critère de fin de partie ce qui peut
arriver mais qui est dommage elle vaut
mieux terminer la partie sur l'échiquier
voilà donc on a fait le tour des
vraiment de la présentation générale sur
7 sur 7 le son du jeu d'échecs un
historique on a vu donc l'échiquier avec
le positionnement des pièces et celle
des retards énormes des pièces essayer
de retenir les tonnes et non des pièces
revoyait bien la vidéo avec les tour les
cavaliers les foulées pions la dame est
le roi la position l'échiquier les
colonnes les ranger les diagonales et on
a à peu près tout vu
c'est bien d'apprendre l'historique
aussi du jeu et puis les tic très
important tout ce que vous expliquez
nino pour toucher une pièce si vous
touchez vous de bhl à jouer si vous
l'avez lâcher ses jouets et les règles
de serrer la main tertiaire au début à
la fin de la partie
voilà vous avez les bases pour rentrer
dans le monde merveilleux du jeu
d'échecs et aller plus avant dans la
connaissance de ce jeu voilà je crois
que c'est fini pour cette première
émission où ils ont passé peu horaires
déplacement des pièces
on verra ça sur seulement voilà sur une
autre émission que vous invitons à
découvrir sur diagonale tv le son est
spécial débutants on remercie d'avoir
suivi cette émission mémoriser tout cela
avant de passer à la suite merci
mininova revoir au revoir
[Musique]